[音楽]
[拍手]
はいじゃあよろしくお願いしますまず皆
さんこれらの生き物をご存知でしょうか
まず知ってるっていう方いらっしゃいます
でしょうかあちらほらいらっしゃいます
ありがとうございますまこういうアメリカ
ザリガニとかこの牛ガエルといったその
外来種による問題っていうのが増えてい
ます
っていうのもこの例えばこのアメリカ
ザリガニなんかはちょうどこいですね6月
1日からあの条件付き特別外来種という
ものに指定がされましたあの在来種に対し
て悪影響を与えてしまうということから彼
らはすごい悪者のように見られてしまって
いますしかし彼らは本当に悪者なの
でしょうか私がこう思い始めたきっかけは
中学1年生の時に遡ります中学1年生の時
にまザリガニの解剖していたところまこの
白い石のようなものが出てきたたんですね
でこの白い石について調べてみるとあの
遺跡と呼ばれるものだということが分かり
ましたでこの遺跡というのはこのザリガニ
が脱PAする直前に生成される石のことを
言いますまこれが私がそのザリガニを研究
していくきっかけともなりましたでこの
ザリガニの研究を進めていくうちに
ザリガニがその外来種としてその農業にも
被害を与えているってことが分かりました
そこで私は実際にザリガニがたくさんいる
とされる千葉県のイバ沼というところまで
行きましたまそこで現地の農家の方にま
実際にこのザリガニによる被害はあります
かっていう質問をしたんですねでそこで
質問するといや全然ないよって言われて
本当にない困ってもないって言われてぜ
そんなにないんですかみたいなでその時に
ま目に見えるような被害っていうのは全然
なかったんですねただその時に自分はその
目に見えるような被害がないからと言って
あのそのままほっといてもいいのかって
すごく疑問に思いましたでそこで私は生体
系保全やその生物対性というに詳しい五家
公一さんという方とお話をさせていただき
ましたその時に五家さんがおっしゃられれ
ていたのがこの人とその自然というのが
適度に付き合っていくことでま生体系と
いうのは対応になるとおしゃられていまし
た例えばそのあの里山というのは生物多様
性が高いということが知られています生物
多様性っていうのはあの色々なここで言の
はその色々な生き物がいることによって
受けられる恩恵などのことを言いますで昔
はまこうあの人が山に定期的に入って木を
伐採して水田を作ってで米を栽培してと
言ったようにま人によってそうやって恩恵
が得られるだけじゃなくてまその色々な
生き物が生きられる環境というものが構築
されていまし
たではなぜ私たちてこのま生きててま多分
沖縄の海とかそういう綺麗な山とかまそう
いう豊かな自然を干してると思います
しかしなぜ現在そういう人とその自然の
多様性について考えないのでしょうか今
私たちがこうやって例えば毎朝毎日食べる
ような野菜だったり肉を食べれてい
るっていうのはその様々な生き物があいる
ことによって受けられている恩恵の1つで
もありますしかしその現在人と自然との
関係性というのが気迫になってしまってい
ますこのことがその外来し問題だったりを
始めとする多くの問題をむ根源的な原因と
なっていますあの皆さん多分普段そんな
生物多様性について意識されるってことは
まずないと思います例えばそのインバ沼の
農家のように自分たちにその直接的な被害
がなければまなかなかその生物多様性と
いうことを気に止めるっていうのは難しい
と思いますなんですけどこういう豊かな
自然をこの支えていくのは多様性であって
この多様性を維持していくためにはその人
と自然というのが適度に付き合っていく
ことが必要不可欠なんですそこで私はその
人とその自然が離れてしまったことによっ
て起きているこの獣害と呼ばれるものに
着目をしましたでこの獣害っていうのがま
何なんだって言とこの獣害っていうのは
その野生長寿例えば鹿だったりその
イノシシだったり最近ではその日本ザルと
かもそうなんですけどそういう野生鳥獣に
よって引き起こされるま被害のことを言い
ますで私自身その小さい頃からその
キャンプに行った際に見るその鹿とか
イノシシっていうのにとても興味があって
興味がありましたなんですけどその時彼ら
によってその重従が起きているってことは
全く知りませんでしたなんですけど現在
その司会の趣旨による野生長寿によって
引き起こされる農作物の農作物への被害ま
いわゆる獣害というのが進になっています
外も昔はその人とヤのバッファーゾーン
干渉地帯でだった里山が機能していたって
いうのとまあとはその漁師さんがいた
おかげでそういった獣害というのは防げて
いましたしかし現在その人とその自然との
関係性というのが気迫になってしまって
いるというのとその漁師さんのそもそもの
数が今減少してしまっていてその鹿や
そもそもイノシシを空らないま食べない
ためにそういう獣害が増加傾向にあります
で実際にこの令和3年度にはその野生鳥獣
による農作物の弊害っていうのがま155
円にまで登っていますで私はそこで実際に
その獣害の被害っていうのを知るべくま
千葉県の漁師さんに出入りをしてきたん
ですねでそこでお話を伺うだけじゃなくて
ま実際にあのここ今写真映ってるのはお話
を伺ってるところなんですけど実際にあの
鹿とかイシをカあの捕獲して解体する
ところまでも一緒にやらさせていただき
ましたでそこでこのお話を伺うとま今って
その鹿とかイノシシはかるんだけどま9割
近くは廃棄されてしまっているという風に
おっしゃられていましたでまた当たり前の
ことなんだけどその捕獲したその鹿とか
イシっていうのはま無駄なく利用しなけれ
ばならないよねという風におっしゃってい
ましたではなぜ現在これだけの数の歯の
趣旨が駆除されてしまっているのでしょう
かこの原因としては今その鹿とかイノシシ
を解体してくれる解体場って呼ばれるもの
が存在するんですけどもうそこが今利益が
得られない状態になってしまっていて採算
事業になっていますこのことがまその9割
近くが廃棄されてしまっている原因の1つ
でもありますそのためその鹿やイノシシを
狩ることでその人によって何らかの利益が
得られるというサイクルを生みその人と
自然との持続的な関わりが生まれるように
しなければならないんですそこで私はえ
ジビの啓蒙によって人と自然とを
つなぎ直しと考えましたここであちなみに
なんですけど備食べたことがあるっていう
方どのぐらい今いらっしゃいましかああ
結構いらっしゃいますねありがとうござい
ますここで言まジビエというのはフランス
語でその野生長住のその肉だったり料理の
ことを言い
ますでそこで私はそのまジベってすごく
美味しいんですねま食べたことがある人は
分かると思うんですけどジビてとても
美味しくて栄養感も高いということが知ら
れていますま最近なんかその鹿肉なんか
特に鉄分が多くてま妊娠している女性の方
の体にもいいという風に言われています
そこでまジベを食べる人が増えてジビへの
需要が高まりそうするとその漁師になる人
が増えるのではないかと私は考えました
そこでま漁師になる人が増えれば山に
関わる人が増えると考えました私はその
ジベを食べることでその山に関わる一員と
なってほしいという風に考えましたでそこ
で私はこの思いからもっと手軽にジベを手
にして欲しいと考えてジベの販売アプリと
いうものを考えましたこのアプリの機能と
してはその消費者とそのえっと師の方を
直接つげるっていうものでま漁師さんが
取ったそのイの趣旨なんかをその消費者の
方に直接届けてあのその消費者と消費者と
その漁師を直接つげるというものですま
こうやって消費者とその漁師を直接つげる
ことによってま解体上の方々も採算が
取れるようになるのではないかと考えまし
たで今回えここまでこの獣害だったりその
外来種問題についてお話をさせていただい
たんですけどこの獣害だったりこの外来種
問題っていうのはこの特に都会にいては
なかなか気づきにくい日知な問題なんです
ま皆さんも多分都会にいてまなかなか
そんな獣害とか外来種問題ってま聞くこと
だったり直接的な被害を受けるということ
はないと思いますなんですけどこの獣害や
外来種問題というのは本当に彼らが悪いの
でしょうかそうではありませんこの獣害や
外来種問題が起きるような環境を作り出し
てしまったその人間人にもも責任があり
ます例えば今日1番最初にお話をさせて
いただいたアメリカザリガニなんかは本当
に外来師問題の典型的な例としてよくあげ
られるのですがアメリカザリガニは元々は
その牛ガエルを養殖する際の餌として日本
に運ばれてきましたなんですけどもう今は
まあの身近な生き物となってしまうぐらい
もう繁殖してしまっていますし獣害も同じ
ように人人によってあの人が自然と離れて
しまったことによって起きていますその
ため今起きているこういう外来種問題とか
従っていうのは人が引き起こして人に害が
戻ってきているとも言えるんですそのため
ま人が人が生きていく人と自然っというの
は切り離すことができないからこそ人が
生きていく上では自然と適度に付き合って
いかなければいけないんです人と自然の
結びつきっていうのをもっと強くしていか
なければなりませんまじゃあ実際にその人
と自然との繋がりを強くするためにま何を
すればいいんだこれはすごく難しいんです
があの本当にこれは難しくて今聞きに来て
くださってるような方々がまいきなり
山に行って鹿とか命書借りますなんていう
のは本当に不可能ですし難しいので本当に
最初は少しずつでいいと思います自分の短
でき身からできること例えばまジビを食べ
てみるということから始めていくのはどう
でしょうか本当に少しずつでいいのであの
自分自身その行動を起こすためにはまずは
興味が必要だと思っているのであの今回の
このトークがこのその皆さんの行動を
起こすためのきっかけとなってくれれば
幸いですご清聴ありがとうございまし
た
H